big makeup products you will not catch
me using because they contain harmful
ingredients to our health there's just
so much nonsense here because she's just
repeating what these terrible sources
like
consciouslifeandstyle.com and Yuka are
saying but it is a pretty good
illustration of some bad arguments that
clean beauty uses so I'm making a bingo
card let me know what else you think
should be on it first off she goes on
about carbon black this is just bad
because of impurities but the purified
versions are allowed everywhere C1 she
tells you to read this for yourself but
she's showing you the super outdated
version if you go to the ntp site they
take you straight to number 15 the old
version is actually really hard to find
online so that is an E1 carbon black is
bad for you only if you inhale a lot of
it so that is an A1 and a B1 BHT is
toxic at large doses like everything
else so B1 Canada has a separate list of
ingredients not allowed in cosmetics and
BHT is not on it I've made industrial
use a separate Square because they do
this enough that it should be its own
category